i dropped some eggs he like accidentally
made the cut stranger things is one of
the biggest tv hits
of all time due in large part to its
amazing cast
along with being incredible actors it
turns out that they're also some
seriously
impressive improvisers even though the
show's scripted
some of the most impactful moments from
all three seasons were actually
improv like some hilariously awkward
unscripted moments that even
the most professional actors couldn't
keep a straight face for
it was not written in the script because
it was not written
one of the most infamous unscripted
moments in stranger things history was
the kiss between max and lucas
in season two well the actress behind
max
sadie sink who was only 15 at the time
and had never been kissed
was not told about the big moment before
arriving on set
but when ross duffer joked about it and
she freaked out and became extremely
uncomfortable
he decided that he just had to add it in
just to mess with her
he said in an interview that it was her
fault that the kiss was added in because
she reacted so nervously
you were so freaked out that i was like
well i gotta make her do it now
uh do you remember being 15 we do
and having our first kiss in front of a
crew of hundreds would have freaked us
out too
even though it all turned out okay in
the end the moment sparked an important
conversation about advocating for the
rights of young actors on set
millie bobby brown and finn wolfhard
have grown super close over the course
of filming stranger things
which makes for some amazing on-screen
chemistry just check out this adorable
scene of the two of them playing around
i never gave up on you i heard
you can't fake that kind of friendship
which is what makes the fact that their
very sweet scene in the grocery store
from season 3 was
actually all improv even better
poor mike is struggling to find the
words to tell elle that he wants to get
back together with her
and we all know how hard that can be i
just like i've never felt
like this you know with anyone before so
when finn started going off script and
trying to find a way to confess his love
for her
the directors absolutely loved it and
told him to keep going like like
old people say to each other sometimes
some actors will do just about anything
to stay in character
even when it terrifies their co-stars
just ask anyone who's ever worked with
jared leto
is he crazy well it turns out that dager
montgomery who plays the only human
being who has ever been intimidating in
a mullet
philly takes after leto in his own way
daker was so determined to stay in
character as his psychotic possessed by
evil forces character that he threw
caution to the wind
and almost broke his own skull during a
take i've done things max really
bad things in the harrowing sauna
sequence from season three
billy was only supposed to scream at the
kids from behind the sauna window
but instead he went ahead and smashed
his head against the thick glass so hard
that it actually
shattered luckily he walked away with no
lasting injuries
and no one can say the reactions he got
from the kids weren't totally authentic
max get away from the door what get away
from the door
the entire sauna episode was no easy
feat not for
anyone involved apparently it took four
days to shoot the emotionally wrought
sequence
and by the end of it everyone was
completely exhausted
no one more so than millie bobby brown
whose showdown against billy drained
both the character
and the actor physically and
psychologically
i was walking every single day director
sean levy said that
all of the exhaustion you see on screen
is completely real
and that the moment when eleven
collapses into mike's arms and start
sobbing
wasn't in the script at all but was just
the actress herself falling apart
and we don't blame her you can see finn
breaking character and looking over at
the director for guidance before
wrapping his arms around millie to
comfort her
she's such a dedicated actress that it's
easy to forget how young she is
and what a toll this kind of work must
take after so long
11 is me like 11 is just who i am now
even though he had tormented her and
everyone around her for the entire third
season
when it came to the final moments
between billy and eleven
millie bobby brown decided to show some
empathy for his incredibly tortured
character
right at the very end eleven sees into
billy's memories
and reminds him of a day at the beach
with his mother long before everything
went wrong in his life
turning him into a monster you told her
the wave was seven feet while it wasn't
in the script
she reaches up and touches his face
which when you think about it
is probably one of the only times that
billy has ever experienced real kindness
since his mother passed away
moving on to something a little less
tragic remember the hilarious breakfast
scene between nancy murray and jonathan
you know the morning after well it turns
out that one of the funniest parts of
that cringe-worthy brunch was entirely
made-up
brett gelman who plays murray is one of
the best comic actors out there
and when he saw an opportunity to make
the painful scene even more
uncomfortable
he had to take it right after asking a
few innuendo heavy questions about how
their night on the pull out couch was
gelman accidentally dropped a fork full
of eggs
instead of just picking it up and
continuing he instead said this
oops you can clearly see natalia dyer
doing her best not to burst out laughing
at the ad-lib
and we don't know if we could have been
that strong either
david harper's hopper try saying that
three times
is one of the highlights of the show
even if he can be
seriously grumpy sometimes but his
grumpiness really does come from a place
of love
and it only makes his character more
endearing when you say date
just so that we're crystal clear about
things yeah stop talking i
changed my mind while he has said that
he doesn't improvise a ton of lines
he adds in a lot of different behaviors
that are definitely not on the page
one example of this kind of thing goes
all the way back to season one
on the page it was really written as a
sweet caring scene
but instead harper decided that hopper
would try to get jonathan to toughen up
and approached it from a way
tougher place even going so far as to
punch him on the shoulder
you're crazy crazy
you wanna see real crazy back when she
was first getting to develop the
character of eleven
millie bobby brown decided that she
wanted to find a few moments where the
young girl could be a little bit funny
even if that wasn't in the script at all
one of her most iconic moments was
totally improv
that's right it's the eggo scene in the
script they had eleven go to the fridge
and pull out
one or maybe two boxes of waffles but
instead
millie had the idea to take just about
as many as she could carry
and honestly who can't relate to that
excuse me
a young lady holly wheeler nancy's
younger sister
has been on the show since the very
beginning and you might be surprised to
hear that she's actually played by two
twins
anison and tinsley price the price
sisters were
only two years old when they started
filming the show so they weren't given a
whole lot of lines
none in fact literally everything that
holly has ever said on screen has been
improv
and most of her reactions as well it's
okay ollie it's just a loud noise
it turns out that two-year-olds are
pretty priceless in their reactions
so if you turn a camera on them you're
bound to get something great
i'm gonna blow some daylight into that
thick skull of yours
no harper has had some great fights in
stranger things history
but his battle with gregory was one of
the best and apparently
all it said in the original script was
they fight
which isn't much to go off of but
working with their stunt coordinator
they had a great time coming up with the
epic showdown and based most of it off
of the indiana jones movie raiders of
the lost ark
they even got to throw some action hero
lines of their own into it
you wouldn't do that why's that
because you're a policeman after hearing
the story of how millie bobby brown
actually collapsed into finn's arms out
of exhaustion we have even more respect
for this dedicated cast
they really bring so much to each of
their characters especially when they go
off bug
and we cannot wait for season four how
about you
thanks for watching